ni hommage la coupe d'europe ni hommage
des championnats d'europe avec l'équipe
de france pendant trois mois et demi je
pense que vous ressentez vous cette
indisponibilité
il faut faire contre mauvaise fortune
bon coeur et puis savoir que le match
n'ait route valeur d'un métier très
difficile et il faut subir les
conséquences et de très très bons
moments et à des moins bons
bon bah si l'indisponibilité qui va
durer trois mois et demi ça va être long
mais j'ai beaucoup d'amis roman rien la
fracture des malléoles dont a été
victime michel platini l'accident kit
des skieurs résultat d'une mauvaise
position de la jambe d'appui dans une
posture d'efforts cet accident conjugué
à celui de merchadier sorti hier de
l'hôpital et qui se remet d'une rupture
du talon d'achille ajoutez aussi l
opération du ménisque de chloé porte à
trois le nombre des titulaires nancéien
désormais indisponibles j'étais pour une
opération bénigne à la marge ouen
d'abord le jour de mon opération
maintenant c'est michel ou des blessures
assez graves pour l'un comme pour
l'autre les carrières groupe
la carrière européenne de la snl l'anssi
est fortement compromise nom bien
compromise je ne pense pas parce que
même quand même deux effectifs cette
année heureusement parce que c'était la
dernière
maintenant on aurait fait mais enfin
disons que évidemment sans michel sans
enfants alain et puis peut-être sans moi
c'est sur ce problème assez difficile